foreign
shisha
okay okay do you want to introduce
yourself
it's because it's too windy and that's
why I'm crying it's not because of me
[Music]
and you're supposed to tell me what I'm
going to get tofu
tofu yeah or like fried tofu or Nando's
like
London
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
what I need bubble tea foreign
[Music]
as well
just say one thing at a time okay well
okay
[Music]
is that one thing or two things
it's eggs no but we do need that feeling
okay
oh my God I sound so bad
it's not that bad thank you what was the
other thing
that's all you have oh my God
thank you dark right yeah okay
yes
yes I don't get it I liked it yeah if
that's your name yeah is money no un is
money
yen is water oh I didn't say it's salt
sodium food
show me if you know what it is
corn flour that's all the ingredients oh
I'm following this recipe by the way
oh
get a plate so
get a ball yes
you got one
you get one why are you shaking your
voice no don't shake it up one one
one you shaking your voice no but you
sound different you get one I'm trying
to say one ball it doesn't sound right
one you're supposed to encourage me I'm
trying to learn
um
[Music]
I'm just saying this and now I sound
foreign as well
[Music]
can you tell her
you're too tall that you love him
yeah I feel like I sound pretty cool
when I speak Chinese or anything yeah
yeah
means good yeah
because she was Kakashi
I'm living in Chinese recipe
so
[Music]
you focus on your camera work
how much quite large you want to cover
the whole time yeah
[Music]
yeah
the only thing you can recognize
[Music]
you know what you're getting with it I
feel like you learned a lot of Chinese
today I actually did
come on mate come on right mate just a
few minutes it's all happening very fast
what are you doing
sorry I'll go over there it's fine that
wasn't a lot
you made me beat up and this is what
happened my life
you do
shopping
be careful
as well
put the soy sauce yeah
oh
[Music]
should I call you
what cut does it spring on you yes so
how do I cut these cheers
if you know what I mean
okay let me show you like what I mean by
cutting off under
oh how
this is harder than I thought it would
be
what are we gonna do with the egg we'll
make something else
me yeah like me but like this rice in
Chinese
[Music]
that's why I want to put it in the bowl
so I know how much we're gonna eat
[Music]
I'm not gonna wash the rice yeah we're
gonna wash it
me
some water like one finger above the
rice this one is
yeah that should be funny
[Music]
we're just putting down the oyster sauce
and we realized we actually didn't even
use the oyster sauce yeah we didn't
it might taste like not that great oh
well we'll try the best yeah but if
you're making this recipe yeah remember
to put the oyster sauce that we forgot
well now it's the do you know what the
good thing is it just made it vegetarian
now it's vegetarian and we've got two
flatmates who are vegetarian yeah it's
all good so maybe it was meant to be so
they can try it as well all right
positive that's still positive yeah when
you look at the positives
foreign
but she can do it I can do it
why don't you have a career stuff if you
die then will not have it okay
guys I think I might need it
[Music]
you're very much
okay it's because it's very stressful
yes thank you
let's love it
[Music]
yeah
well done to us I mean it's like very
basic but not in a bad way yeah comfort
food
it was actually really like it I'm
definitely gonna make this again
see also in the fork
I'll embarrass myself
[Music]
one more time hope you enjoyed this
consider subscribing I'll see you in the
next one
[Applause]
[Music]